there's a story about facebook
ending bans on post asserting covet 19
was man-made the story came about last
week it's a wall street journal story
facebook has ended its ban on posts
asserting covet 19 was manmade or
manufactured a policy shift that
reflects a deepening debate
over the origins of the pandemic that
was first identified in wuhan china
about 18 months ago
president biden on wednesday ordered the
u.s intelligence inquiry
into the origins of the virus the white
house has come under pressure to conduct
its own investigation after china
after china told the world health
organization that it considered
uh beijing part of the investigation
complete calling for efforts to trace
the viruses origins to shift into other
countries
let me read this one more time folks i
want you to list i'm going to read it
slower
the white house this is a wall street
journal article this is not us writing
it
this is wall street journal the white
house has come under pressure
to conduct its own investigation after
china
told world health organization that it
considered beijing's
part of the investigation complete let
me get this straight i'ma read it one
more time
white house has come under a lot of
pressure con to conduct its own
investigation because china told
world health organization that it
considered beijing's part of
investigation completely like listen
we checked on it already don't worry
about it it's okay america
nothing really happens you don't need to
do anything calling for efforts to trace
the viruses origins to shift into other
countries
earlier this month a group of 18
prominent scientists called for a deeper
investigation into the circumstances in
which the virus emerged
including the possibility that a
laboratory accident released it facebook
in february began to ban on claims the
virus was man-made or manufactured as
part of his list of misleading health
claims
that aren't allowed so so here's here's
my problem with this here's my problem
with this
look uh it's march
of 2020 we find out this virus is
i think the first person died and the
you know the shutdowns was taking place
you know disneyland all this other stuff
that was taking place
trump goes and travels flights from
china
what does uh biden call racist
xenophobic
racist what does nancy pelosi do she
goes to chinatown
and says look these are good people and
he says wait a minute what are you
talking about i'm banning this because
it could be man-made
the moment anybody on the right said
they released the virus you know what
they call those people
conspiracy theorists the word conspiracy
theorists the moment somebody tags the
conspiracy theorist on you
what happens to you you lose credibility
you know what's crazy
the whole scandal with russia for three
years that was the ultimate conspiracy
theory
ever there's never been a bigger hoax
than the russia
scandal the dossier that clinton's paid
35 million
there's never been a bigger scandal than
that that was a scandal
the moment it came out that it was a
scandal and was a conspiracy theory
the ma the media stopped talking was
just kind of like oh the russia scandal
is not real
okay but let's talk about this year
because wait wait wait no no no no three
years you've been talking about this
address this no no
no no no we're moving on we have to go
no no you just talk okay
so they are there's so much hypocrisy
there because a year ago
the democrats had only one plan and
here's what the plans were
and as a registered independent who
thinks bill clinton was a decent
president
who thinks me who thinks bill clinton
was a decent president he was able to
get things done with newt gingrich
me first president i shook hands with
was bill clinton
the independent guy here is sitting here
saying a year and a half ago you
silenced anybody that said it could be
man-made
because in your mind you only had one
thing in mind
we have to figure out a way to blame
covet on somebody
who do we blame covet on one person if
we do china the guy gets reelected
because it brings the entire country
together you know who we have to blame
we blame trump because if we blame trump
we win the election
everybody went off of russia story they
went into the china story
trump's fault they put all the pressure
on default on trump
and what does trump do here's what trump
does he gets elected a week later
vaccine comes out he loses the election
a week later vaccine comes out who did
that
but fauci said it's going to take 18
months to have vaccines oh i'm sorry
fauci brought the pressure no trump
brought the pressure the handling of
covid
may have been one of the greatest
handlings of a pandemic a president has
done
without any training on it no one's been
talking about
training on this for a long time no
one's gone through it
no one's gone through it at this level
we're like oh here's what we gotta be
doing
this guy handles it well he handles in
the right way
they divide they pin it on him after he
loses
five months later all of these guys have
a conference call and not they want to
say
could be man-made and facebook removes
how many billions of views of people who
had opposing arguments
about this being man-made was taken down
how many doctors who did an interview
with abc talking about hey
this virus how many of those interviews
were banned remember that whole
african-american
african doctor that went up there and
she talked about it she got like
hundreds of millions of views taken down
the doctor from bakersfield taken down
why because it's an opposing view i'm
sorry so what is a conspiracy theory
what percentage of conspiracy theories
are right this whole alien thing was a
conspiracy theory
everybody's not talking about aliens
this whole jfk thing was a conspiracy
theory
everybody's talking about jfk
assassination all of these things you
call the conspiracy theory
guess what they just did as a person
who's a hardcore skeptical guy
myself as a person who's hardcore
skeptical
you know what this whole nonsense about
facebook saying we end ban on posts
asserting covet 19 was man-made
you know who won here's who won
conspiracy theorists
one they won you now have to sit there
and say
i'm sorry these conspiracy theories
weren't conspiracies
maybe there was some weight behind it
it's not okay to do that look
charlemagne god calls out kwame brown
hardcore
okay talks about his family and all this
other stuff you know what charlemagne
did
here's what charlemagne did he got up
then he gave an apology beautiful
apology i listened to the whole thing
this morning in six minutes
hats off to charlemagne uh media
are we getting an apology facebook the
judy mike of its interview that was
taken down the
the virologist that was taken down all
the opposing stories that were taken
down are we are you
are you going to give any credit to what
happened to the last administration or
is this is china is
kova still trump's fault is that what it
is oh now is china's fault
here's a biggest opportunity we missed
on this this is what upsets me the most
and i'm going to wrap up because we got
five i don't hear your thoughts and
we'll wrap up we may not even get a
chance to go into the what do you call
it the
logos because we got the other thing
adam here's what upsets me
the most um had such an
opportunity last year for america to be
united man
we had such a big opportunity last year
to be
united 911 united us
we had such a big opportunity to get
united last year we missed the mark
who caused it partly trump because you
wouldn't uh uh
uh prevent what he can be in the whole
divisive like the last two presidents
prior to biden they've both been
divisive obama was the divisive he was
divisive
constant dividing and then the left the
media everybody we had
such a beautiful opportunity last year
for america to come out being stronger
but we came more divided
we missed a massive opportunity because
we could have shared one common enemy
and it would have been who china but you
know why we couldn't have done that
because if
last year we would have said china can't
trump in trump would have been
re-elected you know and that's one way
of looking at it and a lot of people do
the the democrats were so obsessed with
trump and their only objective was to
get him out
russia didn't work i mean they tried
like hell to have that work it didn't
they had
no this is people's theories now the
other thing the byproduct of what they
did is they knew if the economy would
tank
that would be another big role in trump
not winning and that was another
byproduct of this whole thing and and
the saddest thing about it in my opinion
is we did miss an opportunity to become
united and have this
be something that can draw the country
together but there's certain factions
that just don't want that
and the the mainstream media is one of
them unfortunately that's not good for
their business and it's not good for
their model
so you're not going to get those types
of stories or the truth in some cases
where that's going to
you know happen where the country's
going to be united and as a matter of
fact they're going to go the opposite
direction very very hard
i'd like to see where facebook goes from
here because if they're basically saying
we're ending the ban
um are they going to give some reasoning
some justification
like what's the what's the story i don't
they don't have to do that the guy who
went on james o'keefe and who was a
former facebook employee and he uh said
all the stuff that he said facebook
fired him the next day and said sue us
do whatever you want to do
do what you got to do well i think the
silver lining here and i do agree with
you
that whether it was the media whether it
was trump whether it was
kobe whatever it is everything has
gotten so politicized
and we are as divided as ever i i would
love to see
the country rally and unify against a
common threat or common enemy of china
and um as as someone who gets the label
of the resident
leftist here uh i could tell you that uh
we are equally concerned with china
and about time adam i would say about
time because about a year ago you were
not
uh well you're upset with me that it
took me a while to
come around no no no no no my my
frustration is the fact that
many smart individuals like you mr mark
my my and by the way we all go through
this at some point in our lives you're
not the only one
you know what you know what the biggest
challenge is is those this is the
problem adam if i give you the problem
this is the problem
you know how you're like here's here's
what's starting to happen in america
which is actually not a bad thing
the problem is when republicans see
i think sean hannity says and they're
like i don't know if i agree with that
but i have to because i'm a republican
right you know uh anderson you know i
don't know if i agree with that i'm
a democrat yeah i agree with that
you know i don't know if i i agree with
that
you know that whole thing that's what
everybody went through last
12 18 months everybody's longer than
that yeah no but but but yes you're
right it was because of trump
uh let me just remind you real quick i
was a registered independent
full-on my entire life i've never voted
for republican president so
that's but i was a clinton guy but what
what's your point i was like
but you say that as if like you are like
you've probably never voted for a
democrat but of course
would you vote clinton
what year what are you talking about you
voted for clinton what are you talking
about
my point is this here's my point i was a
registered independent yeah
and then when trump showed up i became a
democrat okay
so now that he's gone it's a lot
easier to be an independent thinker this
was trump's
gift and curse you're either with him or
you're with him against him
and for someone who was against him he
could not you could
you you you were against him emotionally
yes
whether i was against him emotion more
logically is irrelevant
not you but people don't have common
sense because of their hatred if you
would have seen them and that's my point
if you would have seen the policies
there was no palestine israel issue
there was no isis
issue there was no gas issue there was
no economy issue there was no wars
there was none of that there was fake
russia which was fake
you know was fake yourself we've talked
about this that was the ultimate
conspiracy theory where for three years
all we heard about is the fact that this
guy's got a dealing with russia
and he's got he's on the inside with
putin it's all we heard none of it was
true
what happened kovit came best crisis for
the left they used it they kicked him
out
and boom he's out now we're dealing with
all this other stuff that's going on
today
so that part yeah i have a problem with
that and uh
yes i'm glad finally many people are
finally realizing the real enemy
the last 18 months has not been trump
the real enemy the last 18 months has
been
one country and it's china and now you
want to say
you couldn't say last year because you
had to blame trump on it last year
you're finally figuring out this you're
not you
you being biden in the camp on the other
side that's saying
and you voted there's also 86 million
people that voted so to label people
blind or yeah i think they are i i
actually do believe i do believe
majority were blind because we didn't
because the main what is the main main
method of where
majority of people get their information
two places what are they media and
social media media and social media both
are controlled on one side
yes you're right both are controlled on
one side hollywood one side
sports all all this most of the sports
commentators what side are they on left
yeah what side are they on name me one
right guy that's a big name
a sport he won't have a job troy eggman
troy aikman is a football guy yeah okay
he's a commentator who else outside of
troy
you are joe buck who else joe buck who
else give me
anybody from espn that stays there
anybody from espn that keeps
smith oh really the guy's on the left
who else do you think stephanie smith is
in there 100 percent he's on the left
adam adam are you kidding me you're so
we've talked about where do you think
steven a smith yeah i think he's i think
he's a center left guy but he's on the
left oh i thought you thought he was on
the right no i think he's a center left
who
if you talked about his real values that
his mom taught him he'd be the center
right but he can't i'm good with anybody
who's center left or center right
the problem i have are the leftists or
the complete
right autocrats out there that's my
biggest problem
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
you